it has been reported that dr. doom is
going to be making his MCU appearance a
lot sooner than we thought coming in
Phase five in black panther 2 very
exciting news but now the question is
who is going to play this infamous
Marvel villain in fact that's been a
pretty big question since Disney
acquired the rights to the Fox
characters such as the Fantastic Four
the x-men Galactus the Silver Surfer and
of course Doctor Doom who is going to be
cast to play all of these characters
when they finally make their MCU debut
well not too long ago Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige opened up about
Keanu Reeves making his way into the MCU
and it is possible that he could perhaps
be playing Victor Von Doom if you're new
be sure to subscribe with notifications
turned on like the video and leave a
comment down below so you can enter my
xbox one and ps4 giveaway so again in
case you haven't heard
according to Charles Murphy of the
Murphy's Law podcast Doctor Doom is
going to be making his MCU debut as the
main villain of black panther 2 in phase
5 according to his sources and although
there hasn't been any information yet
about who could be cast to play Doctor
Doom in black panther 2 we know that it
has to start soon because we know the
date of black panther 2 black panther 2
is coming out on May 6th of 2022 so we
have over two years but when it comes to
movie production and movie development
that's not an insane amount of time it
literally takes years for a movie to
come together and although we're still a
little bit away from the casting of
black panther 2 we know it's a priority
for Marvel especially if they're going
to introduce the very first Fox
character so it's a super-important
casting role and that could go to Keanu
Reeves backtracking to before when there
was a ton of hype about Keanu Reeves
possibly entering the MCU as possibly a
Wolverine or mr. fantastic Kevin Feige
actually spoke up and said that they are
indeed trying to find a place for Keanu
Reeves in the MCU and that they have
actually met multiple times to talk
about it but they're waiting for the
perfect character for him and this was
actually confirmed not too long ago in
June of 2019 in an interview with comic
book calm the person interviewing him
asked Kevin Feige a couple of actors I
want to ask you about Keanu Reeves you
guys talking to him for anything and
which Kevin Feige replied we talked to
him for almost every film we make he
think
continued to say I don't know when if or
ever he'll join the MCU but we very much
want to figure out the right way to do
it
so in this interview Kevin Feige
confirmed the fact that they are trying
to get Keanu in the MCU in fact they're
trying so hard that they talked to him
about every single film that they make
to try and see if there's a role for him
but of course it's Kevin Feige and it's
Marvel and they want to do it the right
way they're not just going to shove him
into any character role after all it is
Keanu Reeves everybody seems to really
love him right now so he needs that
perfect character one that is going to
be around for a long time in the MCU and
one that people will like and that
character could be doom now this role
would be perfect for Keanu Reeves for
several different reasons one is that he
kind of has a personality similar to
Doctor Doom he's very suave but he's
also very intense another is that Doom
is one of the greatest Marvel villains
of all time but sometimes he is forced
to team up with the heroes but it's also
a perfect role for him because Doctor
Doom is going to be in the MCU for a
very long time we know that the next 10
years in the MCU are basically going to
be leading up to a battle world type of
event there have been reports that
Doctor Doom is going to be the grounded
MCU villain and that Galactus is going
to be the cosmic MCU villain and these
villains will of course be built up over
time like fan OHS was so they'll be
around in the MCU for a long time and
will ultimately be the big bads of the
huge crossover event like Avengers
endgame it's the perfect opportunity to
get Keanu Reeves in the MCU because it's
a major character that is of major
importance unless Marvel pulls a fast
one on us it will be the first Fox
character to be introduced into the MCU
they have to do it right they have to
pick the right person
doom is one of the most infamous Marvel
villains and characters of all time and
he'll be in the MCU awhile which makes
it perfect for Keanu Reeves
now as Kevin Feige said he's met with
Keanu Reeves about every single MCU film
that has been developed so we know that
he's going to meet with Keanu for black
panther 2 and unless they're planning on
introducing a new character that is
going to be an ally to akanda the role
that he would be meeting with Kevin
Feige about would be the role of Doom
and perhaps they would decide that this
is indeed the perfect role for Keanu to
play in the MCU and after all there was
a rumor going around not too long ago a
about Keanu Reeves possibly playing dr.
doom so this could come to fruition I
think it would be absolutely fantastic
if he played Victor Von Doom in the MCU
but let me know what you think is this
the villain that you would like to see
Keanu Reeves play or would you like to
see him play somebody else be sure to
comment and let me know like the video
and subscribe when notifications turned
on to enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 and to stay up
to date on everything relating to the
MCU as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof